I remember somebody threatening me on
the street because some people did
object to the film getting made and all
that and I remember people saying that
they were going to do me harm and stuff
like that you know and I would actually
go like I remember somebody somebody
warned me must have been a friend of
mine who was crazy early on the internet
and they warned me they called me up and
they went there's some person and they
know where you walk every single day and
you go down this back alley and they say
that they're going to jump on you and
they're going to rip your cerebral
cortex out of your head so please don't
go down that alley so of course I was
like I'm going to that alley I want to
see what happens unfortunately nothing I
kept walking up and down here going
where are they come on
never happened